il y a une nouvelle marque de smartphone
qui vient de se créer et qui veut
réinventer le concept des smartphones
résistant pour là où dort tu vois en
tout cas elle rentre beaucoup plus sexy
beaucoup plus petit beaucoup plus fort
avec les smartphones pour la hauteur le
général sont des gros blocs un peu très
costaud un peu très épais alors il reste
lourd soyons clairs je pense dans la
main c'est un beau bébé mais pour autant
le design est quand même beaucoup plus
fin beaucoup plus sympa ils vont venir
apporter des éléments de couleur
derrière pour venir les différencier
faire un truc très sympa alors vous avez
ce nouveau smartphone qui est tout
nouveau qui vient d'arriver qui a un
côté un peu très brillant alors les
traces de doigts sont vraiment là soyons
clairs donc ça risque d'être rapidement
sale pour l'extérieur mais vous avez
toute cette touche au niveau du bloc
photo lumineuse qui est assez joli et
puis vous avez également un autre modèle
aussi qui est très sympa avec ce petit
orange qui est sympa qui lui par contre
va pas salir et le nom de la marque vous
allez me dire quel est-il mon bon
monsieur gros c'est III il y a trois i I
i I F-150 l'innovation que je viens vous
montrer regardez on regarde plein de
smartphone on regarde plein de
nouveautés est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéresse est-ce que vous
êtes vous client de smartphone pour la
route d'or et est-ce que vous leur
reprochez des fois d'être un petit peu
trop épais un petit peu trop mastoc et
est-ce qu'un format comme celui-là
pourrait davantage vous intéresser bien
évidemment vous marquez ça dans les
commentaires